have you heard about the growing threat
in Los Angeles it lurks in the streets
and patrolmen are on the lookout because
the threat could show up most anywhere
lately it's been police officers that
come by and they're trying to literally
book us for anything they can turns out
he's the threat and so are they
whatever excuse they can find for us to
leave they'll find it and you know try
to use it for you know to make us leave
they operate taco trucks which pull up
to curbs and offer much more than tacos
care for a tofu bowl maybe some Korean
barbecue they're good food their
reasonable price and they got friendly
you know customer service customers seem
happy but truck owners say they get
citations for all sorts of infractions
from parking too close to curbs to
parking too far away I actually went to
court yesterday for a ticket they gave
me they cited me for something which was
repealed in 1995 this isn't the first
time the LAPD has targeted street
vendors Elizabeth Palacios spent 45 days
in jail because of these guys
bacon-wrapped hot dogs the Health
Department says they're dangerous so
unless vendors buy expensive government
approved equipment they're tiny
businesses might get dumped in the trash
Palacios points out that she pays taxes
and holds a variety of permits same for
taco truck owners who must have a
business license a Health Department
permit and a food handler's permit best
things that you have to have in the
truck all the time without those things
taco truck owners may be fined or even
shut down by police they can buy just
ask for all the documents and actually
so I had to go back to the office and
get the originals they were just really
really picky about everything they just
wanted to find something to kick us out
so why are cops cracking down on taco
trucks turns out local restaurants don't
like the competition the only thing that
the restaurants can actually do to you
know prevent us from coming here is you
know hassle the cops or the cops come in
hassle us
we were just offering alternatives to
the people that work in this area and
they want us to be here
well we would either the restaurants if
the prices were reasonable and the food
was good so it's competition you know
it's fair competition I think LAPD has a
lot more things to do then you know come
out here to Miracle Mile and hassle you
know taco trucks I'm pretty sure there
are more serious problems that are
happening throughout LA so our taco
trucks really a threat maybe it depends
if you're a customer or a competitor